so Glenn I want to start with you
because I believe that you were in
London when there was a different set of
directors Richard and Jill Purdham who
were working on the film could you set
up a little bit about that early
incarnation of the film and talk about
what some of the gestation was and and
the change and and that how that
happened well it it was a pretty
wonderful time to be able to for my
family to go to London we'd never been
outside of the states and it was there
that I started really thinking of myself
as an artist keeping a sketchbook which
I've kept ever since then and as we
started to develop the story Richard
Purdum had a very European classical
approach to to telling the story and it
just wasn't entirely Disney though it
seemed there was a reason that Walt went
to Europe and took artists and pulled
them to California there was something
very American that that happens out here
in America when you tell a story and it
didn't take long for Jeffery to realize
okay we need to get this get this back
on the the drawing boards in the States
and I remember we had just spent oh like
about a couple months working on it and
Don flew out to Florida to meet with
Jeffery and they had a screening and we
were all anxiously waiting for him when
he flew back and he said well I've got
some good news and bad news
well what's he says I'll tell you the
bad news first
everything you've done the last couple
months is thrown out we're not going to
have any of it the good news is we get
to be here in London and Europe with
another three weeks with nothing to do
except just go let's go explore the
Loire Valley and that's where we found
decent castle and started to do the
research and it was a great bonding time
then for our team fantastic so
Don I think the next phase was to you
were already on the project so the next
phase was to bring to decide to make it
a musical is that right and and Howard
and talk about the new team it was
brought in yeah there was a little film
that came out before us called the
Little Mermaid and Howard Ashman and
Alan Macon who were are songwriters on
this film I had brought brought Broadway
to Hollywood it's the simplest way to
say it and and reminded the audience how
much we love musicals
in movies and so it wasn't too much of a
leap to say well maybe we should bring
them on to our film and music hole is it
and take what was kind of a European
version of the telling of the story and
turn it into something that was uniquely
musical and and it's really important to
point out Howard Ashman at this point
because he was more than just a lyricist
he was a mentor he was a coach he was a
storyteller and in so many ways the guy
who kind of held our hand through this
whole thing explaining so much about
telling stories and music in animation
and kind of taught us along the way so
one of the biggest privileges of this
movie I think we would all agree would
be working with Howard and what he
brought to us personally in our lives
but also what he brought to our movies
and to our audiences fantastic yes
I think we'll hear more about Howard a
little bit but Gary you and Kirk had
only directed a film I think cranium
command is that right for for Epcot it
really good film that is correct yes so
so how did this how did this come to you
guys and what was your reaction when
you're suddenly is told okay this is
your next project
it was a surprise to say the least
Kirk and I had just gotten off of
cranium command this this 90-day project
for Florida it feels like just a few
weeks prior to this and we're kind of
settling back into our routine of we
called it daycare it was development but
Brenda you were there it was just we
were that we were the artists that they
didn't know what to do with but they
didn't want to fire yet so nothing
because I want a point on it you know so
they are boss Charlie Fink called Kirk
and I into his office on a Monday
morning this is after Don's good-news
bad-news and said can you incorrect me
on a plane Wednesday to New York you
might get to direct beating the beast
and we thought it was candid camera
you're looking around for the hidden
cameras and so the reaction was shocked
it was like total total complete shock I
mean the only thing I can think of is oh
well we didn't screw up cranny in
command I guess I still want us